we go to i-teams at david charns who is
in the newsroom with what one expert
is telling us david yeah christian the
shock waves of this verdict are being
felt
right now all across our country the
world watching as former police officer
derek shovin put his knee on george
floyd's neck
for nine and a half minutes many of the
jurors who just convicted chauvin of
murder and manslaughter had never seen
the entire video
and to put that time that length of time
into perspective
nine minutes ago we hadn't even seen
final jeopardy yet right here on channel
eight
about uh during our last program now you
could say the smoking gun in this whole
thing was that video
i talked to tyler parry who is an
associate professor of
african american studies over at unlv
you know this is what separates so many
past cases
from this one in particular in that
the video itself was so long and you
could see the callous behavior of shove
and that
it is undeniable that regardless of
whether or not he was using a move that
was endorsed by the minneapolis pd
that that in of itself is a problem that
that even would be allowable
in trying to detain a suspect of a crime
during the trial chauvin's attorney
tried to convince the jury floyd had
died of a heart condition
drug use even carbon monoxide coming out
of the police
car clearly the jury didn't buy that
remember juries have to agree as a group
whether or not to find a person jury
now one big question we've gotten here
at eight news now is what
is metro doing to prevent this kind of
incident
as we all watched it unfold i'll show
you their new procedures new at five
o'clock